last year in November I was invited by
wit live college which is part of the
University of Toronto to come and do two
events for them and so I decided to put
up I might put up both events but the
reason why the hesitating is because
there's no image they only gave me the
audio and even in the event I'm putting
up today the audio isn't great it's
especially for some of the participants
it's not amazing but the reason why I
thought it was worth putting it up is
because it is a discussion between three
artists of course myself I'm there and
there's also a contemporary painter and
someone who makes short movies and some
television the it was under the guise of
art and faith how three Christian
artists coming together and discussing
it about how art and faith are coming
together or how there's a dialogue
between the two in their art and I
thought I held it for awhile I mean you
know it's February now and I got this
audio in November but the reason why I'm
finally putting it out is because
listening it listening to it again I
realized it's a very important
discussion because it shows you the the
big difference there is between
contemporary art the contemporary art
practice and also traditional art let's
say liturgical are the type of art that
I make the the three proponents are very
intelligent very well-spoken and so it's
a very interesting dialogue that happens
between the three of us and how
different an approach it can be to move
into contemporary art or rather to
embrace traditional eyes the way that I
have so I think that it'll be worth your
while to look into it just to hear how
how different worlds can come and
discuss sometimes clash but also
sometimes let's say come to agree on
uncertain elements let's say so
so please enjoy
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
just like to welcome you on behalf of
Wickliffe college and imago to our faith
in arts evening I hope this will be the
first of many opportunities for people
to gather to explore the dynamics of
faith and the arts tonight we are
privileged to have three wonderful
Christian artists to share a little bit
about how faith informs and affects
their art forms and afterwards we are
inviting everybody to continue on to
nuit blush the public art exposition
here in the city just by ways of
introduction I want to introduce each of
our our panelists today so on the far
right we have Jonathan pazzo
Jonathan graduated with honors from
painting and drawing program at
Concordia University in Montreal during
the late 90s quickly disillusioned with
contemporary art sorry Phil but he
discovers icons and traditional
Christian images along with his own
spiritual journey rekindling his love of
art through the study of traditional
form jonathan develops passion for wood
carving while living in Kenya for
several years he also discovered the
properties of a certain type of stay
light called the kisi stone have you
studied Orthodox theology and
iconography at the university of
sherbrooke since 2003 jonathan has been
carving different types of liturgical
objects his carvings have been
commissioned by priests bishops
laypeople the United States Canada and
Europe his work is also represented by
major liturgical art companies including
Demaryius and Roble Robitaille in Canada
and New World
Byzantine studios in the United States
he's also the editors and contributors
of the Orthodox arts journal and also
teaches icon carving with hexamer on
nonprofit organization dedicated to the
sacred arts so I like to welcome
Jonathan here
Gloria Kim was born in Seoul and is
based here in Toronto and she comes from
a long line of media makers with a
degree in English Lit from the U of T
she has worked as a journalist at
McLean's she attended Ryerson image and
arts in 2008 can the dryer sense image
in arts and the 2008 Canadian film
centers directors lab her short film
rock garden not a love story is
described by Adam go in as absolutely
beautiful has won numerous prizes
included that including the CBC Canadian
reflections award her CBC film the
auction premiered at the 2010 sprockets
TIFF in one best short film the audience
choice award 2012 whiffed short film
showcase in the children's journey prize
Seattle Film Festival for children and
is now part of the John Van Duzer film
collection at the TIFF Bell Lightbox
other major works of one their numerous
golds and Bessey's the marketing awards
one club her OAC commissioned work why
do I dance has almost a million views on
YouTube since April 2012 and she was in
the 2009 TIFF talent lab so I'd just
like to welcome Gloria Kim here
[Applause]
and last but not least Phil Irish for
fulfill painting has become a way of
exploring the world stimulating the
imagination and sparking deep exchange
with others he earned his master's of
Fine Arts from York University Toronto
and his Bachelor of Arts and in fine
arts and English literature from the
University of Guelph exhibitions at
public museums artists rent centers and
commercial galleries including the
Oakville galleries Tom Thompson memorial
gallery gallery Joyce Gunda and jelly
gallery a Kay artist run Center his
contributions to the francophone
international painting competition was
exhibited at the National Gallery of
Canada laminate dart Quebec City's
biannual featured his work as having a
group of exhibitions across Canada and
the United States he has developed his
new work during residency's in
Newfoundland of the symposium in by
saint st. paul quebec and as the city of
Kitchener artist-in-residence Irish
applied his painterly vision to a
web-based artwork for Oakville galleries
in 2007 he was shortlisted for the
Kingston Prize Canada's national
portrait competition Phil lives with his
family in Ellora Ontario so Thank You
Phil for coming out tonight and I just
like to introduce also our our panel
moderator for this evening Patricia
patty Patricia patty serves as a
communications director here at
Wickliffe College and she has a deep
long passion for the Arts and how that
intersects with faith and she's more
than happy to be up here exploring a
very important topic with with our
guests tonight so thank you Patricia for
being willing to do this tonight thank
you everybody
so thank you Steve for the introduction
and thank you everybody for coming out
tonight to engage with our panel on this
wonderful rich deep topic and I'm sure
we're all going to go home with much to
ponder and reflect on tonight so and
thank you again to our panelists we're
going to start with kind of a general
question to get our panel warmed up and
then I'm going to have a question for
each of you pertaining to your own
particular art form and then we're just
going to get into some discussion and I
hope that you'll feel free to to just
talk back and forth and engage with one
another and hopefully we'll have some
time for some questions at the end so
just to begin with Eugene Peterson I'd
like to start with a quote by Peterson
he has said that instinctively we
recognize that there's more to beauty
than what we can discern with our senses
instinctively we recognize that there's
more to beauty than what we can discern
with our senses so what do you think
about that true not true do you agree
disagree I'd agree so if beauty is just
something in the senses and that's just
thinking about things like no rhythm and
color and pattern which you know that's
that's what a formalist artist might
really be leaning into all those things
are important I love love that but I
think we use I think we use the beauty
to also talk about about meaning to talk
about kind of patterns in life that
something might evoke for us so all of
those things start to reach beyond just
the senses right you bring your memory
you bring your mind you bring your
experience you bring your suffering in
your hope all of that so so a deeper
layer with beauty I think would touch
all of those things
what do you think Gloria I think of
beauty as connection I mean for me
what's so important in art is feeling
some kind of a connection and maybe
that's super simplistic but I do think
that without that it's hard I mean like
that's how I perceive beauty and it's
something that moves me and there's very
much a sense that it it engages the
spirit right Jonathan what do you think
yeah I I like I like the way Gloria
presents this notion of connection I
think that that's that's a good way to
understand beauty is when you look at
something and you see that the things
fit that somehow things fit together
that it should be that way and so what
it does is that it actually points us to
truth there's something there's a
relationship between beauty and truth
and and it has to do with how things are
coming together in a manner which
intuitively is right and I think that
that that is something that can be Anna
Gajic that is that it can help us to
understand God that it can help us to
understand the way that God created the
world that that brought things together
this notion of fitting together in a
manner that is good and so I think that
beauty can actually be a portal for many
people especially in a world that is so
random and somewhat ugly you know we're
the the world of you know strip malls in
and concrete I think that this
apparition of beauty can really be a a
surprise that can remind people of this
deep connection that we have you know we
always in the in the Orthodox Church
there's is this trope that everybody
group
that is somewhat from Dostoyevsky but is
really from soul generation which is
that duty can save the world that beauty
will save the world and it to understand
it in that way that it will save the
world because it reminds us that it
shows us how deeply connected things are
together that's how it can save the
world
so I fully agree with you with Peterson
with Eugene Peterson good ol Eugene okay
I'd like to give each of you an
opportunity to tell us a little bit
about the medium in which you work and
we're going to start with you again
Jonathan if that's okay so you carve
icons and I understand that the process
of painting an icon is almost a
liturgical process that certain prayers
are said before the painting and even
during the process that certain music is
played what about carving an icon is
that a spiritual act of worship for you
I think I think that it can be it also
sometimes it's not what you talked about
this this way of making icons it's a
very it's a very it's it's it's somewhat
video sync Radek it's a very new thing
this idea that that you say certain
prayers before and everything it's it's
it's a very recent phenomena that things
are done this way not I would say that
most professional icon carvers don't do
it that way because when you do it for a
living you're doing it all the time and
so you wake up in the morning and you go
to the workshop and then you carve icons
and so there are moments where really
you do feel like everything is coming
together and if you have this prayerful
spirit and you look at the person that
the saint that you're carving or this
image of Christ and you can feel the
connection developing as the figure is
appearing and there's this process but
other times you know just had a fight
with my wife or you know some someone
someone said some horrible thing on
Facebook that I can't get out of my mind
and so then I'm just it just it becomes
a job and we we have we also we have to
be careful because sometimes I have had
the surprise that people tell me
that this icon this is this icon is so
full of you know grace and and I know
that when I carve that icon I had no
crazy just I was a complete wreck when I
was making it and it so we have to trust
that you know that in our home you know
that you know by the grace of God you
know that sometimes these things happen
God can use us even if we're not Saints
you know in all our human frailty right
yeah awesome that's amazing thank you
for sharing that Phil you specialize in
big bold creations and it's been said of
your collage paintings that they assert
the need for transformation I'm
wondering what that means to you and is
that impression something that you
consciously set out to create when you
make your art yeah so I used to make and
well made him do some of these again but
I kind of you know rectangular paintings
and formats that close to what you might
expect I was always kind of playing with
it and pushing it but I was going
through a point in my life with a lot of
turmoil on a lot of layers and I began
to make painted surfaces but then cut
them up and collage them back together
again so this act of taking something
that is kind of stable that you can
attach meaning to in a certain way and
then to break that thing and have broken
things all over the place and then to
pick up those parts and recombine them
together in a new way that became the
visual language that really excites me
and I've been working in that direction
for the last five years or so and so the
idea of transformation is is critical so
I mean you can still see that as a
viewer when you walk into the space you
can see oh that you know this was a part
of this and this has a cut through it
and I wish I could see the other half of
this but it's gone so you get a very
clear sense of fragility and sometimes
even violence of something breaking and
yet well the way I put them together
there's a kind of rhythm and energy and
life to it that feels yeah so I was
thinking with this like things fit like
they fit together there's a kind of
wholeness to them and yet another aspect
of it is that you feel like you could
still move some pieces so they they
haven't come together to an extent that
they feel timeless and frozen right they
feel like this could continue to change
it's beautiful but it's broken and it
can still keep changing and that for me
reflects my sense of of life and also of
faith right like you you know some
things but some things are broken and
and how do you find hope and what do you
where are we heading and can you start
to see that in the work but without it
being a closed answer yeah it's a it's
provisional innocent okay okay thank you
and Gloria I've watched some of your
short pieces on Vimeo and I was really
struck by the contrast in them between
beauty and the provocative and I'm
wondering if you could talk to us for a
minute about that tension as a filmmaker
and and what do you see as being your
primary motivation
I started making films it was really
because like I talked about connection
and beauty and I really wanted to
connect like I wanted to I think when
okay just as a human being you know you
walk in this world you feel like a freak
you feel disconnected from everyone else
and what I did and I just what I wanted
was to kind of say like this is who I am
and I see you and I know you feel kind
of the same things that I feel maybe at
different times and a lot of times we
just don't talk about that stuff right
all the stuff that maybe whatever it is
that we're going through in our days and
for me art was a way of talking about
stuff and connecting people to stuff
that we don't normally in polite
conversation talk about like at a party
or you know whatever at a bar so that
was always kind of my motivation and
then I ended up like because when you're
making work and you're trying to
convince people to give you money to
make work you have to there has to be
some kind of like whatever is that
you're kind of pushing the envelope on
you have to be able to kind of justify
that right and say like look there's
this audience or there I'm serving some
kind of you know thing where people will
want to see and so the stuff that I
ended up making like my first films I
did for CBC it's like a trans fantasy
fable and like there's a really really
like rabid niche LGBTQ audience and so I
got funding for the film and then it
ended up doing really well but what I
really wanted to talk about was identity
right and within that culture and that
subculture and who are we and can we
accept ourselves even if we are a freak
you know because or the way that the
rest of society sees us and yeah so
that's I mean everything I've done has
been kind of around like okay how do I
find funding for this
because it's an incredibly expensive
medium it's it's there's a very labor
intensive there's a lot of gear like
it's just creating the landscape of any
film is expensive and then how do I say
what I want to say around whether it's
like that story or I did a little
children's story but it was like the
story of you know like it was like an
immigration story so that was kind of
like the political angle that I could
find the funding for but also it was
really a story about a little girl who
sees her parents for the first time as
people right that because that was what
I wanted to talk about all right so it's
just kind of like it's I don't know like
that like I thank you for saving my work
is provocative that's great that's
awesome
and I have been told that before and
yeah I just I don't know like I just
like to talk about stuff that maybe
people I don't know might be a little
bit uncomfortable talking about but I
don't know like I guess because yeah
it's that whole thing like when you are
an artist and you come from an artist
heart and you feel so deeply about
everything and you know you walk in the
world you can't pretend not to feel
right like I think that's the reason why
I'm always like oh like I see this story
and I see you and I see your humanity
and let's put a this create a story
around it so yeah I'm struck by each of
you I I have this sense of around
artists people who who make their living
full-time as artists and I think it's
easy to put people like you on on a
pedestal but as you talk
you all are really so honest about
sharing the the nitty-gritty of what
it's really like to engage in your art
and so I'm just wondering if if you
could talk for a minute just as a panel
about that contrast between creating
like recognizing you spend your days you
make your living creating things that
are beautiful or reflective of truth or
that are intended to inspire people and
yet you have this other side of life
that's about paying the bills and you
know dealing with the kids or fighting
with your spouse or those things so
how'd it how do you how do you come to
grips with those two sides of you know
what what life is for you as artists one
thing I love about being an artist as it
touches it grows out of everything that
you're excited about in life right like
there's you know my family shapes my
work my faith shapes my work all of
those things feed in you know you're
you're curious about something and then
you're reading about that thing and all
these things you're reading about tie in
and I'm a real sketchy book keeper and
there's all these things that I you know
it all you know sometimes you put
something in there that just seems
irrelevant and then a little while later
you look back and you realize that feeds
that that's feeding this question that's
becoming some new some new project right
so yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I I
another side of it is that I also teach
studio somewhere so the money question
is is daunting sometimes I've made
pretty good money sometimes less
but the kind of family relationship
money question is a little bit taken
care of since about five years ago I I
took the precarious roller coaster down
and no option and so my family's happy
about that it could academic death well
I don't know just yeah I mean so so some
some of the some of the turmoil maybe of
your question is and that has what does
that allow me to do I mean that's
allowed me to make some crazier things
which it which is good so it's like yeah
it's given it given a certain kind of
freedom in a certain way to make to make
things that aren't stressed about that
money question day to day so little
little confession for you know I didn't
I didn't actually didn't I don't feel
like I decided that I was going to be an
icon Carver I never actually decided
that like I don't I think no rational
person could decide that in Canada of
all places I was kind of I kind of it
kind of happened to me just very yeah I
I was long story I was in Africa for
several year for seven years and it's
when I came back I was looking for work
and I just felt like every project that
I was starting was never working so
nothing was kind of panning was was it's
coming and I had this secret prayer that
I could be making the Terkel art but I
never thought it would ever happen so I
was kind of doing it on the side trying
to survive psychologically as I was
trying to find work and you know putting
up a little website writing emails and
and then after about a year and a half
of just not nothing coming up I you know
I was in prayer and I was like you know
what's what is this like god what is it
did you want from me I don't know you
know I came back to Canada I thought
this was the right thing to do but then
nothing is happening and and it's like
it dawned on me that I had slowly
accumulated about $10,000 of
missions for carving and so that was the
only thing in front of me it was the
only thing I had and I said okay I have
here's a step I'll just take that step
and I just took one step at a time and
that's it like I just never stopped
since and in terms of money I've seen
miracles constant they just constant
miracles I've I've gotten checks in the
mail from people I don't know I've I've
three times someone has given us a car
you know just non-stop you know we come
to our house and find bags of clothing
on our porch and we have no idea where
it comes from and so it it's just
somethings like I think that I think
there's a truth that if you if you kind
of I mean I don't think everybody's
called like that like that that God kind
of shows you a path and you kind of have
to go or else you're in trouble it's
like I felt like that's what it was is
like God was saying okay this is the
step you have to take and don't worry
and I'll take care of you and you know
and that's what happened and doesn't it
doesn't stop the fact that I'm still
like the Israelites in Egypt in the
desert they go oh constantly I'm looking
I would be looking at my bank account
and thinking this is absolutely insane I
have three kids what am i doing and then
just some crazy miracle I kind of people
call me and I like a certain amount of
money and someone calls me and said you
know I wasn't praying and God kind of
nudged me to send you this check and it
was just the exact amount that I owed
and it's just this constant thing so you
I think that I think that when you I do
I've come to believe in though in my
darker moments I don't actually believe
it but I can say that if you trust God
that things are gonna be okay yeah I
have often said it's my faith journey
like very definitely I mean I was always
a writer I always wrote when I was
little was a little kid and like I liken
it to channeling like you're basically
you're connected to source and source is
basically telling this story through you
and you're the answer
really right like your experience and
your whatever your body is the
instrument through which the story is
told so obviously it's you know like
situated in me as a you know Korean
Canadian woman I hate so that kind of
story kind of really flows really easily
for me but definitely like the
filmmaking aspect of things
like I found directing and like out of a
writer's block that came out of a trauma
that ended up helping me find my voice
and every step of the way like every
film I've ever made has been nominated
for awards won awards you know I've
always had funding for my films and like
I am also a very big believer that if
you trust if you just keep walking the
path and yes it's a very scary path I
think we all think yes it's you nodding
your head there my friend yeah it is a
kind of terrifying thing you really are
kind of just basically making the leap
and you're saying okay god catch me
gonna be there because I'm jumping and
I've definitely made a lot of choices
that like that which I think like maybe
more sensible people wouldn't make but I
think but it's an act of faith okay a
hundred percent an act of faith it's a
great way to be alive right like yes
like all the parts of our stories right
all all the complexity of that and it
makes the work deep right yeah so what
what a joy to be able to live that way
everything that was put in me right to
be able to use everything that I was
given that's how I feel when I make
films
so I you know I have no regrets how does
your faith inform your arts miss a
question for all of you how does your
faith inform your art or vice versa how
does your art and form your faith how
does it influence yeah I think that it's
you know it's a very rich thing it's
also a very subtle thing so sometimes
you get that question and people are
looking for you know a very one-to-one
this illustrates that right and and so
so that's that's what's tricky about
that is to try and figure out okay how
how really do I understand that you know
part of part of it is about about the
mystery of God and and the things you
don't know so much of art is following a
question and and my faith is kind of
like that too
where where you one of my sort of
repeated thoughts to myself as I'm
working this is just to trust the
process right Trust trust that that good
will come out of the things that you're
making both in terms of the visual
effect of it but also how it will touch
people yeah I might I might tell one
story that that is maybe a little more
explicit but it's an interesting story
that's also about crossing boundaries so
I guess one of the one of the dangers
okay if I make something that's really
faith explicit am I gonna alienate an
audience but on the other hand art is
beautiful at crossing boundaries where
where because you're not saying
something in a cliche way that pisses
people you know that are think they're
turned off by faith you know because
you're coming in from a different angle
it can really open doors so I live in a
small town and there's a woman there who
is a tarot card reader and so she
travels around and she realized that a
bunch of places are making these decks
of cards where the cards are made by
artists instead of being kind of
traditional cards so she thought why
don't we take our small town we all make
a card and I'll sell these decks all
over the world so she's calling up
different people and and she calls me up
and you know I have a little moment of
feeling uncomfortable right it's like
okay tarot card what's going on how are
people seeking plans for their future
how are like what's guiding why what's
going on there I don't really know
what's going on so you know maybe I'm
kind of compelled to say maybe it's not
my thing maybe I'm not going to do but
on the other hand what I'm hearing is
okay there's like 40 people from my
village who are creative people who are
getting together to talk about a
spiritual thing and make stuff right am
I gonna be the person who's got all the
answers and I'm gonna say no to that or
am I gonna be the person that you know
like Jesus eaten with all kinds of
people crossing boundaries there's an
opportunity right so what I ended up
doing was I made a card and it is the
seven of Pentacles shows a guy leaning
on a on his hoe looking at a plant and
the plant is bearing fruit in the fruit
is coins with pentagrams on him and
considering whether he's gonna harvest
or not or fertilizer or whatever I could
I can relate to the theme right like
productivity and where you have that's a
good theme I can relate to that so I
replaced the Pentacles with actually a
squash plant has these five pointed
flowers right so I replaced the pen to
the pentagrams with flowers and fruit
there's different stages of fruiting
from squash and then I replaced the
gardener with a Jesus figure from
Frangelico painting which is one that I
love where Mary Magdalene mistakes Jesus
for the gardener so the gardener looking
at the plant is actually you know the
gardener from from the resurrection so
there are all these different things
going on it's multi-layered it's it's
it's
it's a really I think it's a really
interesting painting so it ends up being
in this context where people are talking
about these other things so I imagine
you know somewhere around the world
tonight someone's maybe dealing out some
tarot and they're and they're looking
down going like what's Jesus what's
Jesus doing in my tarot deck and it's
it's led to some really good
conversations and and so on
so I mean that's that's that's kind of a
that was there was a whole faith faith
faith journey to do that and and then
but it also just shows that act of just
letting go right like I can't control
the meaning of that piece it's gonna
mean different things to different
people it's out in the world and you
can't you can't just make it like a firm
message it's just it's just something
that came off ethically out of me and I
shared it with a group of people and
that's that's what you can do letting go
of your art once it's out in the world
it's it's not a hard thing to do as
artists like understanding that people
are going to interpret your art
differently than maybe what you intend
them to take from it maybe has an icon
I'm probably the wrong person to ask
it's not I I make the the objects that I
make are made in a language it's very
different they're made for a community
they're made within a community and
they're made to serve a community and so
when I make an image I'm making it in a
manner to connect with people who
already although I've never seen that
icon will know the tropes of the
language and will know what we're
referring to so if there's this common
language that's happening and so when I
make something I I know who I'm making
it for that is I have someone who writes
me or calls me and says I'd like you to
make this for me and they'll tell me a
bit of their story this you know I'm
gonna give it as a gift to someone or my
child's being baptized and I want
something to remember or there's
something there's
story and so when I'm making that image
I'm making it for someone and so I'm so
happy what's the seed coat because I
know that I'm going to send this object
in that person's life and it's going to
participate in their life and if it's
for a church that it'll participate in
the church it'll be part of the of the
architecture be part of the liturgy part
of the the that community in total it'll
be an image that will enter into a
community and so it's it's more so I'm
not so I don't have that that type of
fear because yeah because it's it's a
different it really is this communal art
hopefully yeah okay
oh of course there's a risk of being it
everything is interpret it because not
everyone has the code that's right
exactly I mean those like you know that
the language of iconography has been
used to do all kinds of insane things
you know make icons of random people or
do you know you put a Harry Potter with
a halo or you know all that kind of
stuff
I mean obviously it is possible but in
general like when I make something
usually I have I engage with the person
I'm making it with I don't I rarely have
something that I just make and then sell
it's always a an interaction and so yeah
so it's it's I at least I haven't yet
felt that I'm sending something out and
to kind of to just be misused or just be
a strange thing for them I didn't want
to ask you all later at some point about
that that idea of you know how much is
your ultimate audience or public for
your artwork in your mind
you are creating that piece yeah I mean
like I think audience is really
important in the terms of like I mean
when when you're making like the kind of
media that I make you you're constantly
thinking about audience cuz you're
constantly I'm selling and you're costly
trying to convince somebody so there is
that so you're always kind of describing
the audience I mean I think the nice
thing about I mean when I think about
art and like what I do and making films
versus say making advertising because
I've also done that it's that with films
it's a conversation right it's like a
conversation and you don't know where
it's gonna go and you're hoping that
someone's gonna hear part of it and like
understand part of what you meant and
the heart of what you meant but it's
always a dialogue right and I think
that's a really wonderful thing about
art is that it is about love it's very
like it can go anywhere and it sparks
things and like it does things like put
a halo on Harry Potter and you know all
of those wonderful things and that
becomes part of the general conversation
and like it just grows beyond that and a
symbology has become this huge thing
that's everywhere and like like you know
you're talking about pentagrams but
you're right it's like you know like
from a flower like a five-pointed flower
whereas something like advertising it's
very much this is the exact audience
this is their income this is the
messaging they call it messaging you
know not that there's anything wrong
with advertising
just but it's just really like very
one-sided right it's like manipulation
yes yes one could say that yes one side
yeah yeah and it's just an arrow
pointing one way right and there is
really no mistake right so I that is
what I think is so wonderful about art
and you know when you're thinking about
audience you're you know you may have an
ideal audience in mind like I have a
feature that I'm making that I'm gonna
be shooting in the next three weeks and
I have kind of yes the audience is gonna
be women it's gonna be you know probably
women who are like more left-leaning
liberal but you know also like for me
the ideal audiences like women who have
been through certain kinds of
experiences and certain kinds of trauma
and you have a need for a certain kind
of a message and but then you're also
like I hope other people like I hope men
see it as well and like sympathetic
men's mute I hope like I'm sympathetic
men see it you know like I hope you know
there's just this some message that
you're hoping yeah that I'm hoping that
will open there but it's like it's like
a heart opening for me my like as
opposed to I mean there is a specific
message yes but really it's about
opening the heart for me right
so let's talk about that idea a little
bit of of Gloria you actually called it
sorry doesn't my word
you called it manipulation but but what
is the power of arts to move people
toward faith do you think I think I mean
like there is a flying I mean okay it's
like there is you know for example
there's my genre like in my field
Christian films I'm not a huge fan of
that genre per se because like from what
I've seen the quality isn't what I would
want in terms of the storytelling mm-hmm
and I think it's so important as an
artist and we talked briefly about this
is how important it is to be the artist
first
like that is just like I think like I
talked about connection right and I just
think think is about connection it's
about longing it's both
[Music]
it's a truth
yeah your message is more about truth
Jonathan what do you think what is the
power of moving of art I think I think
that we when we talk about messaging I
think that we are we are kind of that
the heirs of the rational rationalistic
world we have this idea of what's the
message but we talked about beauty at
the beginning and I think that beauty is
the greatest thing that we can bring to
the contemporary world because we there
is such a lack of beauty and I always
tell people you know when when when
tourists come to a city you know and
know they they where do they end up
visiting the end of visiting these old
churches why why do they visit these old
churches because there's something
there's there's something different
there's some there's some vision that's
there which is different than this banal
kind of McDonald's world that we that we
live in and I think that that's what we
can offer and so I of course I coming
from my perspective I really do see that
in the Christian tradition we have so
much we have so much wealth we have we
have 2,000 years of this wealth and and
so it's not hard to just to look back
and to to see all that this whole
musical tradition we have an
architectural tradition we have a visual
tradition and we have an icon illogical
tradition all these images these
patterns of images which go relate to
the Bible which also relate to the
liturgy which relate to the songs which
relate to the architecture this massive
pattern you know and then the whole
liturgical year this whole way of living
to celebrate different things in the
life of Christ all through the year and
you know different colors different this
whole just this gigantic artwork you
know this this you know when when the
vogner talked about this idea of like
the perfect
to work of our the total work of art
well he was wrong like it's not the
Opera because when you're in the Opera
you're not in the work of art you're
watching it but in in the Christian
liturgical art you're inside and you're
singing and you're in the space and
you're participating in that store and
you're celebrating Christmas and
theophany and and Pentecost and so that
to me that kind of beautiful pattern is
what we can bring to the world we can we
can because it's lacking we have nothing
to celebrate anymore
and so that's I mean that's one of the
reasons why I ended up going towards
something which might feel hermetic to a
certain extent as like making icons very
hermetic but I don't see it that way I
really see it as plunging back into this
giant story not just the actual carved
icon but it's it's just one piece of the
whole kind of liturgical tradition of
the of the Christian tradition and I
think that that giant package is
something which can surprise the world
with beauty so this question and it was
something that Gloria kind of touched on
it was about the idea of you know I mean
she referenced specifically Christian
films and and talked about you know a
certain level of quality but I I'm
wondering when Christians make art there
is definitely the potential for a
prophetic truth speaking to occur but is
there a danger of using the arts as a
cover for just religious propaganda and
if so is that ever a temptation for for
you for any of you really and and if so
how do you what do you do with that
temptation part of what I was thinking
about when you talk about advertising
and talking about that firm message and
about a category called Christian art
which can be
awful
so I mean what makes it awful I mean on
the one hand I mean I mean partly it's
just a lack of ambiguity right it's
trying to be so earnest with the message
that the struggle and difficulty of life
gets taken out right so I don't know
Milan Kundera in The Unbearable
Lightness of being he describes Kitsch
as being the denial of [ __ ] so that's
that's that's his word for it but he he
kind of runs through the whole he runs
through a whole story that actually
deals with Genesis and you know all
kinds of stuff comes in there but it's
this it's this creating a picture that
anything negative cannot cannot be in it
it always has to have sure there can be
negative it all has to get tied up
nicely so I feel a lot more room for
ambiguity and and I think that's also
you know part of the mystery of God I
mean I can't I can't pin it down right
this this this love that calls to me you
know and the life of Jesus all of this I
love but it's it's it's beyond what I
can name clearly so part of what I try
and do in the work is point that way but
with a kind of humility where I'm not
trying to pin it too tight in order to
appreciate the light we have to have
shadow right yeah I mean it's just it's
just it's just what is believable to us
as well right like I love the fact that
in the Gospels you get this whole gospel
narrative but you don't actually see the
moment when Jesus rises from the dead
right they had so iconic lozen is
another topic right that's where where
the images fail us I think that's a
moment when any image you could make
would fail you so there are other
Gospels written non canonical Gospels
that are written later that do describe
it and it's and it's like a bad movie so
but it
the way they handle it is brilliant
right you get before you get after the
moment of actual transition is not
described and so there is at the heart
of it there's mystery right and I think
that's a brilliant artistic expression
of what not to show and what not to be
I mean the Gospels clear but it's also
weird right but it you know I think
that's that's really useful another
thing I was thinking about just talking
about audience is I mean you guys are an
audience I don't know if you're gonna I
got some bikes in the car I'm gonna grab
bike around scene and we launched
tonight but that ambiguity is also an
invitation to you as a viewer to
interpret the work that you encounter so
that's actually something I look forward
to in my audience is that they will
bring their life to bear on the work and
sure sometimes I might be horrified at
something someone you know interprets
but you know other times other times are
beautiful I remember this one time I
made this image with this life jacket
and this note I did a series of life
jackets that had silk-screened on them
safety warnings because actually if you
buy a life jacket they have these weird
safety warnings on them and so this one
was a child's life jacket and it said
notice to parents this life jacket is
not a substitute for parental
supervision so so I had this painting of
the life jacket with this text quite
small on the bottom and yeah so a woman
comes up to me and she says you know
that's my favorite painting in the show
and let me tell you that when I was a
kid I got out of the house and I crawled
across this like fresh tar that was put
on the road and I'm covered in Burns and
she like pulls up her it shows me burns
on her right like there's no way that I
could have thought about that when I
made that thing right and yet how
beautiful right it had a really deep
recognition for her that she I mean she
was passionate about her life and about
parenting and about what kids go through
and she's just looking at this pretty
simple image that I made so that that's
partly why I make it right is that you
you make something and you just hope it
will touch people and but also that they
will have the creativity right to make
something out of out of my starting
point in a sense so you guys should feel
that freedom to you don't have to just
go
I mean it's useful to go okay what did
the artist intent here that's useful
except you can't ultimately answer that
question so another way to ask it is you
know what in the culture does this thing
connect to that's a great way to view
work right and then and then to let
yourself have the freedom to to go as
deep as you can within yourself to to
make make something happen when you're
looking at that work and shift to share
that with your friends it's beautiful
like I love viewing art with other
people and engaging it and so and that's
maybe a different way to think about
audience but talking about looking at
art with other people I mean nuit
blanche is on tonight and part of what
we wanted to do was to to have some
questions about about the theme of art
in the city so let's start there with
why is public art important anybody
I see you know television is public
garden you to this public art right
yeah so I guess I guess the question is
what is that what is public mean like I
would say just because you do something
in public doesn't like I wouldn't say
public art is any art that happens in
public yeah yeah yeah so when I think
about how to define public art it's is
tricky and that okay so one definition
might be it's the kind of monuments that
tell the story of other people another
yeah or metaphorically running out from
that but yeah so another another way we
would be who's paying for it right
so like because lots of things happen in
public space I'm not sure that makes it
I mean otherwise everything is public
art and it's not maybe a useful term but
but the tea but the TV the TV is paid
for by all kinds of grants right so
you're fighting for these grants so then
that becomes public art right has this
public purse
yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah-yeah it so funny I
have such a such a different perspective
on that I don't care if something is art
or not that's I think that that's
irrelevant
I is it interesting and what's its
purpose is what I asked until that's
that to me that's been that for me
that's been the way to kind of deal with
that question to me the art has no value
actually in itself it's actually I have
a much more traditional vision of art
which is that art is the skill to put
things together that's what the word
means like just means the capacity to
bring things together so you have the
art of cheese-making and the art of you
know the art of painting and the art of
architecture the art of rhetoric so
that's how I view art and so the art
itself has no value it's what you're
doing with it which is which has value
and that I kind of click for me was one
of the major clicks because I I feel
like I abandoned I kind of let go of an
idol which is this idea that I should be
making art it's like actually no I don't
I shouldn't be making art maybe I should
be making things with art but what and
so the answer in terms of public art I
think that in that case what you're
talking about you can kind of understand
how public art can have a function in
society it can have a function which is
to bring people together
hence the monument which tells a story
of a people a church is public art in
the sense that people actually gather in
the church to worship together and
Banksy can in some way be public art in
the sense that there's also room for the
questioning of those structures the
questioning of those identities yes and
so and so the right and so the the
yeah so graffiti actually has a you can
understand the purpose of graffiti then
you can say that there's an art of
graffiti which is to poke at you know so
that let's say the church or the
monument is there to establish the
identity of a place or a group or a
people or a story and then the graffiti
artist is the one who comes to poke at
it and you need you need both right you
need the you need the King and the Holy
fool they both have a function in this
kind of this the kind of the totality of
things and so that's how I see art so
for me I would I would I would though I
would think that Jesus is both this is
everything he's the King and the holy
fool so I'd like to ask you this how can
public art work for justice and maybe
maybe you kind of started to hint at
this a little bit with your your
discussion of Banksy and what he's dirty
and there's memory I think that we all
understand that that one of the aspects
of public art is to be an embodiment of
memory and so we see things like
Holocaust museums you see holocaust
monument or monuments that both that can
celebrate an accomplishment but we also
have monuments that can also help us
remember the more scandalous aspects of
our of our past and so I think that if
we can understand it that way as this
and this embodiment of memory then of
course I think public art can play can
definitely play a role in reminding us
of the question of justice so how can
how can we as the faith community do you
know do more to support the creation of
public art what can we do
what's that you don't have an answer
that I haven't answered that have
beautiful churches how about this how
about your church should be more
beautiful than your house at least at
least if your church is at least more
beautiful than your house then that's a
start I think I think yeah there are
lots of ways to engage again engage the
city around you I really I really like
this just back to the monuments a little
bit but the shift from I've been
thinking about the Sir John McDonald
monuments being controversial and some
being taken down or moved right like why
should this one monument stand for our
national unity across time right so it's
a justice question right it does that
does that really represent our ideals at
this time so the public art tonight is
really temporary and that allows a
certain kind of risk and what the
stories are being told so you'll go out
and you'll find all kinds of you know
different perspectives including some
real justice issues so if you go to
Nathan Phillips Square part of City Hall
is draped in burlap bags from Ghana that
are talking about you know global trade
and and refugees and and and we're how
does our economy work and looking at
these questions that that concern us as
as Christians looking for a more just
world so it's taking that architecture
that talks about authority and and
organization and rationalization and
it's it's it's making it kind of
confront something something different
so there are lots of opportunities for
this kind of making making of art and so
what are the resources you have them you
have you have people in the church that
have gifts and how do you empower them
how do you maybe help them to have the
resources and money to be able to do
ambitious things you also have buildings
right like I mean this bill
is almost on the the root right like is
there a way that you can project
something on the building like like
wherever you are just look at what
resources you can have that go beyond
you know to meet people on the street
right as opposed to I mean I love what
you're saying about making churches
awesome so people want to come in and
feel the story but another part of it is
how do you take something to where
people are already that makes them think
differently about the world Iran and
also think differently about their
stereotypes maybe about faith right so
art can there's certain messages that
people get about what Christianity is
all the time we were talking about this
earlier and so it's a it's a straw man
it's a false it's a false impression of
what we're about or at least maybe some
corner of faith is like that but it's a
simplified thing right so when we make
something that that bypasses that and
people have this kind of whoa this is
not setting off my reactionary bells
this is there something else intriguing
here that's different so but but to be
able to do that in a public space in a
public conversation without them having
to come kind of on our terms I think is
really powerful
but yeah so we wanted all of us to
consider is next year there was a
Christian artist
thank you thanks
[Applause]
and we just like to invite you to get
some snacks before you leave but also if
you're planning to go to new me blush I
know some people are planning to go out
Jonathan's planning to go out and visit
why not we go why don't we go together
and just linger around and make some new
friends maybe and so thank you again for
coming out it was a wonderful evening
thank you everybody